last weekend he left this morning today
we learned that he's going to be leaving
ITV entirely is this do you think it's
the last we're going to see of Phillips
gopherd on TV
frankly it doesn't look good and my I I
I have a huge um empathy for his family
um his daughter's wife this must be an
excruciating time for them I mean he's
done all the right things he's had to
resign
um but frankly this wasn't addressed
before
um and you know lying to the media lying
to his agent which I found extraordinary
these stories have been percolating
um lying to the channel who actually
supported him through all this sort of
turbulence in supposedly the breakdown
relationship Holly
um Willoughby is incredibly damaging and
wounding and it will be highly unlikely
that he would find a easy route back
onto television and particularly ITV
um it's it's it's not a good day and um
you know much praise to the son who've
been running this story and be very
diligent about it I suspect
um being proactive about it today they
knew that it was such been pretty major
coming over the weekend and they've gone
running to other newspapers to get as
much as they can out and to do the mayor
culpa yeah and well that's the thing
isn't it Michael how do you think this
this story has has come to our attention
today because of course when uh
philosopher left this morning the um
the thought was that he was going to
stay working for ITV and had they talked
about some shows that he had lined up to
do soon look
um when a national newspaper is
influential as as a CERN have got their
teeth into a story and they know the
truth of the story and no matter how
many super injunctions or or what you
use against it and when the temperature
with the audience changes
um and there is obviously a big story
hanging between you know the truth and
also the flat that's put out it's going
to come out
um and it was only a matter of time I
mean uh Phillip Schofield you know as
soon as he departs from this morning
um Holly is given the golden ticket
um unfortunately you know sad to say
this you know in Celebrity and fame it
turns against you and ruthlessly
everybody is deserted him because of the
truth
um and he's trying to make up for lost
time
um but it's very very difficult when you
are that scale of profile who has been
running away from the story for far too
long and that it finally catches up with
you and uh it's it as I said I repeat
it's a very sad day for his family yeah
it's not the the first time that he's
had to publicly and very um
in a large way apologize to his family
for for deceiving them as you know of
course in 2020 when he came out or
admitted to being gay he also um had an
apology statement that he put out to his
family and you say that the sort of
caliber that the level of star is but
it's also what kind of star Philips
kofel isn't it he's a he's a guy that's
sort of let into your living room every
single day he's he behaves as you know
and conducts himself like a very close
friend and I guess that that sort of
idea of there being something else going
on in the background it's difficult for
for a broadcaster to hold on to
well it's about authenticity we live in
a social media age and um broadcasters
people around it can actually get the
temperament of the mood and the mood was
very
um anti um Phillip Schofield and people
began to smell a rat that in fact The
Smiling soft focus personality that he
was that people shared a cup of coffee
and a cup of tea with every morning
um there was there was something that
wasn't true and you ultimately when you
that level of audience looking you you
you you can't escape that
um and it's uh you know it it's I sort
of have some empathy hoping that you you
can run away from these stories and have
to confront it but we live in a totally
different age
um you know many many years ago the
power of the publicist particularly in
Hollywood actually covered up a lot of
stories
um but that's gone uh that's a different
age now and if there's something there
and newspapers want it and they want all
an exclusive
um they're gonna go for it um and this
should have been dealt with many many
ago some would say that Philip Schofield
has nine lives and he's run out there's
nine lives now you know we had qgate
we've had you know the you know him
coming out declaring his true
personality
um there's been too many of these um
issues that finally has been the the
final stop and he's he's trying to do
the best as he can to protect ITV who've
been very supportive of him of course
his agent has moved away
um his relationship with Holly uh
Willoughby has disappeared
um his fans don't you know you know
don't believe in him anymore
um it's just not a good day for yourself
your brand and where they'll ever
recover I don't know yeah well that's a
Philips go for brand but just a final
thought mark on the on the brand of ITV
and on the show this morning I mean The
Show Must Go On of course and uh there
are Replacements ready and waiting for
that seat on the sofa what kind of
damage you think has been done to the
show Itself by what's happened
I think people have a lot of empathy
with ITV and this morning
um because they've been loyal to him
they've believed him
um they've looked at him and he's he's
denied things to them and um that's what
you've got to do
um because as I said there's huge
amounts of rumors that circulator and
individuals most of it is not true
people actually sometimes don't believe
the facts they actually believe what
they think of someone so I think itb's
priority now is to protect the format
um have a clean break and a launch and
uh move on but I I think that ITV you
know will will be viewed particularly by
people in the business as doing the
right thing of supporting their their
their talent their star because yes
there are lots of people
um who could fill that role arguably
um but he had a great skill it was a
rare individual who could front live TV
he had a fantastic relationship with
Holly Willoughby they were the dream
couple and into breaking that ITV
um would would struggle you know they
will struggle to actually find a
compelling partnership because there's a
lot of focus on that now and um yeah you
know they've got to deliver on this so
they'll be moving on thinking very much
about casting and
um frankly we won't be talking about
Philip Schofield in in a week's time the
agenda have moved on that's how brutal
the world of celebrity is in the 21st
century